the friend Britain had a real problem in
the 1990s because it basically allowed a
number of radical clerics especially for
very key clerics to operate within the
country abu hamza was one of them at
Bukit 8 or another my battery another
and these clerics were allowed to
operate to give sermons to radicalize
youngsters to travel up and down the
country address thousands of followers
and some of those followers then join up
with with with al-qaeda became involved
in suicide bombings cause real problems
for the British authorities in the
period afterwards and certainly by
either expelling some of them or
imprisoning other of others of them that
the problem has been reduced the
radicals now being driven much more
underground at the United Kingdom which
which poses all sorts of other concerns
but at least there isn't this radical
message being put out in the open
anymore in the UK and so that that has
changed the the climate to a degree in
the United Kingdom and you're starting
really to see a push back against the
radicals amongst all sorts of
constituencies within the Muslim
community people who who once had some
sympathy with some of Al Qaeda's goals
in the very least and now going around
mosque and they're saying you know don't
be any part of this this this ideology
is not Islamic and so you're seeing
people who were once involved with some
of these movements now Tony against them
and I sort of pushed back happening
against the radicals in the key thing
there was the july seven 2005 al Qaeda
attack on the London subway system which
really woke up a lot of them was in
community in Britain to the threat of
al-qaeda and turn some people who had at
least a little bit of sympathy with what
some of al Qaeda was doing around the
world and certainly in Iraq and
Afghanistan away from the organization
it was a sort of polarizing
event its it really turned the vast
majority of Muslims fully against Al
Qaeda in the country but of course the
people who were already radicalized some
of them became even more fervently
radicalized by that event energized by
that event certainly the the four
suicide bombers amongst the small
radical fringe of seen as heroes I've
had people come up to me and say
Mohammed Sidique Khan is a blasted
martyr you know he's going to go to
paradise that they see him as an example
some of them unfortunately might want to
follow in his footsteps but for the vast
majority of Muslims and even for some
was him to had some sympathy for some of
Al Qaeda's goals that was an event
really made them wake up and turn
against the the radicals such a lie
seven was very important in London in
really starting up often opposition
against this ideology and changing the
climate